[Music]
netflix um now they're charging 20 a
month by the way netflix is charging 20
a month and people are [__] they're
hemorrhaging users to hbo max now um are
gonna get you back in with a new with a
new show okay
here you go
hello
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
yeah come in yeah come on come on thank
you
oh wow
this is beautiful oh thank you is it
it's nice
i said it was interesting yeah you're
welcome
relax it's not awe-inspiring so i i
understand you want a sex room
you want to guess what she does
make sex rooms
nailed it my name is melanie
for over 15 years
[Laughter]
i've been designing high-end homes so
when a client asked me if i'd ever
designed a sex room i thought why not
why wouldn't i go and design a sex room
if they have that it's called a bedroom
no no no no no no no no no no that's not
the kind of sex room they're talking
about
[Music]
when people hear the word sex rooms they
concentrate on the word sex yeah because
i guess
i'm sorry i don't lick her up a room to
try to [__] it
all right
it's like you couldn't what's the matter
you couldn't do a library or something a
study a sex library a sex library what
would you do there
just all copies of the kama sutra yeah
a sex a sex rumpus room
and that connotates dirty disgusting
wait a minute
don't give us some [__] tap
oh i don't want an old i don't need a
new doctor ruth hey you zoomers we grew
up with listening to dr ruth talk about
[__] and stuff i don't need a new one
i don't need a new dr ruth thank you
very much
but when i design them
they can be beautiful
yeah they're also going to be covered in
[__]
yeah why would you want that much furry
oh my god
that's submersed exactly that's a
nightmare i would want a sex room that
has floors like you know remember like
the kitchens and like a wendy's no i
want this is like rubber and it's you
just squeegee everything into the drains
no no no no we we need a sec a section
a sex room needs to look like the room
that peshy was whacked in
yes exactly
i want to lay plastic down like it's
like like die hard too it should it
needs to look like dexter's kill room
video games no we're not playing video
games in here oh you're gonna play with
your wife instead why do i have to
and they are places where couples
connect
i don't understand any of this kind of
stuff
like this tiny this you know does it get
weird too into that bdsm stuff i don't
know
you're the deepest fan when you when
they start like when this couple kind of
decides to start a family right mm-hmm
imagine trying to convert this thing
into a kid's room to a nursery honey we
have to turn the sex from it to a
nursery
you'd never be able to let your kids
have a black light hey
hey hey virgie where's your sex room
located
is it
is it next to your salt flotation tank
in your sprawling mansion
it's right next to my archery range left
bowling alley oh obviously
this is i would have never thought that
being tied in rope would make me feel
sick by the way brendan shop calls his
f-150 his sex room
that's his mobile sex room also that's
what matt lauer called his office that's
true that's a good point welcome to my
sex room it's what harvey weinstein
called any room it's
sexy oh that's brilliant
wait a second no
no
you didn't jesus christ
i call this work of art monkey parks
[Laughter]
why are they dressed like the baud
villains oh [__] god dude that's the
vaudevillains
curiosity that is being unlocked i have
a great general contractor his name is
mike i didn't break nothing it was the
little guy
it's gonna be those wacky [__] home
improvement shows except they [__]
yeah except with horny old ladies yeah i
always like to make his life a little
bit difficult can you lie on the bed
please
[Music]
hey oh boy
hey
looks so great come on okay
are you kidding me you were our angel
for our marriage
they say you never know what goes on
behind closed doors she got her first
start making uh big boys from outcast
sex rooms
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god this is like christmas
what a perfect bottom
and a beautiful flower
how long do you think it's been since
the last time you know
her
yeah i don't know man i don't want to
think about it i know that